LUKE BAYES: So we're
going to talk about HTML5
Everywhere, how and why
YouTube uses the web platform.
First off, this is
Steven Robertson.
He's an engineer on the player
infrastructure team at YouTube.
Steven makes sure that videos
playback in the HTML5 web
platform across desktop,
mobile, and TV devices.
So he's basically responsible
for video playback library that
runs on a huge spectrum
of device playbacks.
My name's Luke Bayes.
I'm the engineering manager
for the YouTube HTML5 TV team.
So a lot of what I
talk about is going
to be really centered around
how we get HTML5 and video
playbacks on the TV devices.
Steven is going to talk in a
little bit more general terms.
So just to kind of
set expectations,
we're going to talk a little
bit about why the web platform.
We'll go through some
of the challenges
that we faced getting there
and then where we're headed.
So, first off, our
assertion is that YouTube
should be viewable by
everyone on every screen.
Now, when we talk
about this, we're
talking about a huge array
of playback environments,
and it's not just
us that thinks this.
It turns out our users are
really excited about getting
YouTube content no matter
where they happen to be.
And when we say everyone,
we actually mean everyone.
So we're actually running
YouTube around the world.
We're running it on a
huge variety of devices.
We'll get into some of
those details as we go.
And as we try to get this
playback environment working,
one of the things that we
came to a few years ago
was that we believe,
our assertion is,
that the web is finally a
viable option for distributing
immersive experiences
across diverse environments.
So this wasn't true
even a few years ago.
It wasn't quite ready.
And in fact, there
were a lot of things
that just weren't possible.
Our assertion today is that
it's actually possible now,
and even though it is still
a little bit difficult.
So some of the critiques of
the web platform in general
is that it's actually
pretty difficult
to get the kind of
experience you want
or get the kind of
functionality that you want,
and the truth is it
is difficult still.
We do make a huge investment
in getting this platform
to work well.
But we believe that
investment is less
than it would be if we
leaned into native platforms
across the kind of
devices that we're
going to talk about today.
So why?
Why would we do
such a crazy thing
as try to get the web platform
to work in these environments?
So first off, we've got tools.
So a lot of you
might know there's
a huge number of great tools
available for developing web
applications, and those tools
are getting better and better
every year.
They're evolving
much more quickly
than some of the
native platforms
that we've had to deal
with in some of the TV--
certainly in the TV environments
where they don't even
exist and probably never will.
Now these tools
give us the ability
to get visibility directly
into our applications runtime
environment.
They let us debug
what's going on.
They let us profile
that functionality,
let us make it faster.
Some of these
tools are basically
the kind of tools you see
in regular web browser
desktop environments.
But some of these
tools are also the kind
of-- what it takes
to edit this code.
So some of these
native environments
we've dealt with in
the TV world were
you had to pull up
somebody's custom IDE.
You couldn't even use
a regular text editor
to build an application.
So these are very
important aspects
of how we deliver functionality.
Now for us on the
TV team, we also
had a huge issue
with coordination.
So we had to coordinate with
a lot of different device
partners and a lot
of different browser
vendors, a lot of different
people around the world.
And when we were
considering leaning
into some of the native
applications that
are available in
that environment,
the coordination effort
was very difficult,
especially when we
started considering what
if we built our own environment?
What if we built a new platform
that doesn't exist before
and we tried to deliver
that on these devices?
Now that coordination would
involve a lot of discussions
around what surface
does it have?
What are the APIs?
What APIs does it need?
A lot of that
coordination disappeared
when we moved to the web.
So we basically said,
here's some standards.
Implement to those standards.
Here are some vendors
that actually deliver
browsers for these
embedded devices.
You can work with those vendors,
who have a lot of expertise
in getting this platform to
work with these limited hardware
constraints.
And those vendors basically
supported our partners
in a lot of ways.
And some of our partners
leaned into the web themselves
and had engineers on their
teams build web browsers
that worked on these devices.
So the web platform
gave us a lot
of benefits in terms of
the cost of coordination.
Now, we still invest
pretty heavily there.
We work really closely
with a lot of partners,
which I'll get into.
But that cost is
much less than it
would have been if we had
something that we invented,
for example.
We also get huge benefits for
distribution and deployment.
So we have millions of devices
around the world running
these web browsers, which then
runs a single application.
When we run this application, we
can deploy it every single day.
We deploy the production
every single day
for the video player, but
also the TV application.
And we push it out to devices
without any sort of cost there.
We don't have to go through
some certification process.
We don't have to sit down
and say, here's my thing.
Does it meet these requirements?
We don't get rejected.
We simply push our binary to
production and it's out there.
When we have a bug
we need to fix,
that needs to be dealt
with right away, we fix it,
we push it.
When we have a feature we want
to get out, we implement it,
we test it, we push it.
That process is actually
incredibly fast.
And we're able to
use a lot of tools
that you get to use when you're
doing regular desktop web
development like Jasmine
and Karma-- test tools.
We have thousands of unit
tests that run in 30 seconds.
So our engineers are able to
be very productive compared
to some of these other
custom environments we
were facing on the TV.
Now all that said,
we think it's great.
But it's still not--
we still have problems.
We have challenges.
So one of the biggest
challenges my team faces
is in fragmentation.
So we have a hugely
varied device environment
that the TV application
needs to run in.
That involves--
pretty typical what
you'd expect-- we've got some
basic browser vendors like you
run with any desktop
web application,
or mobile web application
for that matter.
You got the Chrome, the
Opera, Firefox, IE, Safari.
Now one of the things that
came for us that was surprising
was that Opera actually
has a huge footprint
in the embedded
device space, and they
have a lot of expertise in
getting those devices to work
well with browser applications.
So for the TV application we
also had to lean into consoles.
So this application runs
on pretty much every web
console out there.
The ones that are
missing are coming soon.
We got this application
running on the PS3
and learned pretty quickly this
isn't like a regular TV input
device.
We've got a game controller
that has a lot of other buttons.
So you get a lot
of functionality
you can add when you're on the
PS3 with a richer input device.
Then we go to the Xbox One
and we learn, oh my gosh,
they've got all these other
input devices like your voice.
You can gesture around
with the Kinect.
We had to add support
for those things,
so we've got another
set of complexity
there to get that to work well.
But we were able to build
that on top of the existing
application foundations.
So we still have a
single binary that
goes out to all these devices.
We have a single team that
implements that functionality.
Then we got to the
Wii U, and we've
got this game that
some of you may
have seen where you
can sort of be watching
a video on the big
screen, navigating
the application on the game pad.
Suddenly we've got the
regular game control,
but we've also got like
touch inputs and a stylus
you can touch around on there.
So we had all these
very interesting input
devices that were very
challenging for our team
to support.
But at the end of
the day, we still
have the same application
that we can sort of put
into these other modes depending
on some of these differences.
And we're able to
lean in to some
of those differences
across these platforms
without having to reimplement
an entire application
and essentially chase
the same functionality
in this environment and build
all the same functionality
in that environment.
We can very easily
add just what we
needed for these
different environments.
So this application,
once we got it on some
consoles we went out and
started talking to other device
partners, people that make smart
TVs and Blu-ray disc players.
We've got this
application running
on pretty much every
Samsung, Sony, Panasonic,
LG-- pretty much every smart
TV, Blu-ray disc player
that has application-like
functionality built into it
or connected devices
that's come out since 2012.
This was a huge, huge
effort, but again it's
the same application.
We then started talking
over to the top box makers,
like Roku, of course
Chromecast, Boxee and TiVo.
We've got this application
running in these environments.
Now some of these have very
different device capabilities,
but they all have
pretty similar inputs.
Of course Chromecast accepted,
which is second screen only,
which is a pretty
amazing experience.
Then we get into set-top boxes.
We're also working with
ISPs and cable providers.
We've got the application
running in these environments.
Now, some of these devices
that these guys have
are actually extremely limited.
They're so limited
that you can't even
put a browser on them.
So there are some
providers they've
been working with that
actually take our application,
load it up on a web server, and
then stream the user experience
directly to the cable
box over a video feed.
And you might have heard
of companies like OnLive.
We've got a couple
deployments already
where people are
using technology
like that to get this web
based application working
in an extremely limited
hardware environment.
Once we started working
with all these partners,
we learned, well, a
lot of them actually
have the same SOC manufacturer.
They actually get the same
software and chip module makers
that basically deploy
into the fundamentals
of their device environments.
So we started working
with those manufacturers
around the world to get
different device media codecs
implemented so we could get
hardware decoding for the codes
that we care about, we could
get some of the performance
improvements we need.
We've been working very
closely with those people.
And as we've gotten
through this,
we now have an
ecosystem that spreads
across literally thousands
of very distinct device
models, hundreds of
brands, and we've
got the same application
running on all of these devices
in an ecosystem
that used to be--
even just a few years
ago-- extremely fragmented,
where you would have to build
tens of different applications
in order to get something
working in this environment.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about this--
I've been talking a
little bit about this sort
of fragmentation.
But when I talk about getting an
immersive user experience, what
I really want to
show you is-- we're
not talking about just getting
something that works at all.
We're talking about
something that works well.
And I'm going to show
you a little bit what's
coming in the TV
experience here.
So we've been working hard to
get a new user experience that
provides all of YouTube's
content on the TV.
And it gives you the
information architecture
that you may have
become familiar
with as you use YouTube,
but from your TV device.
This was extremely challenging
to get working at all.
And we've actually leaned into
getting it working really well.
So when I say immersive
user experience,
I'm talking about sort of a
rich, native-like application
functionality that's
smooth and loads well,
and basically lets you
move around and get at all
the content you're
familiar with.
We've even got like
little parallax tricks.
So we've got a nice,
clean environment.
You can get at your guide.
You can get at
your subscriptions.
And you can actually
navigate all of the content.
So this is coming
out to these devices.
Over the next few months we're
going to be rolling this out.
And this is what I mean when I
say immersive user experience.
All right, see if that comes up.
So, now to get an
experience like that,
it took a lot of
focus on performance.
So we had to really dig
into performance here.
And when we did that there's
a lot of different ways
you can measure performance
and, as Googlers
we kind of look into--
we want to have metrics.
We want to look at charts.
We want to see all these
charts and everything.
And some aspects of performance
are really easy to measure.
So we talk about here,
this is our start time.
This is our
application start time,
sometime around
December of last year
when we really leaned into--
we had a lot of the features
we needed to get
working, and we really
wanted to lean into performance.
How do we optimize
this application?
So we instrumented
the application.
We started getting charts
coming out every day.
This chart here basically has
a yellow line at the bottom.
That's how long it
took for our JavaScript
to download and
become available.
The top line is as soon as
our application interface was
available so a user could
click around the UI.
In the middle are
various checkpoints
that we instrumented.
They're not that important.
But what is important is that
essentially once we looked
into this we saw some
opportunities for improvement,
we implemented them,
and we pushed them
to every single
device that we had.
We didn't have to have
independent teams basically
working on this performance
story and getting there.
Now there's other
aspects of performance
that actually aren't
very easy to measure.
And one feature in
what I just showed
you is as you move right to
left there's an animation there.
That animation takes some time.
So there's a temptation even
with some people in our area
that want to say, hey, I
want to see measurements
for your animated performance.
Well, the animation
takes 100 milliseconds
whether you want to
make it-- if we make it
faster than 100 milliseconds,
it doesn't exist.
So some of these things are
a little more qualitative,
a little more
subjective, and we've
got-- what that means
is that our team has
to sort of own that experience,
a little more the beauty
of that experience as opposed
to just sort of implementing it.
And this is kind of
a different skill
set from your typical engineer.
So we work very closely
with UX and Design to get
that experience to work well.
Now of course we've got the
quantitative performance
metrics.
Then we've got qualitative.
But then we've just
got the raw memory.
So when we get into
these TV devices,
we've got very, very limited
memory, very strong network
conditions, and
very limited CPU.
Now this is a very
different device profiles
than what you might find on
a desktop or laptop computer,
and even on mobile
devices today.
Most mobile devices now
have quite a lot of memory,
twice what most TVs
have, and they also
have-- their constraints are
much more in the network layer.
So you'll make very
different tradeoffs
depending on what platform
you're working at.
But it's nice to be able to
build an application that you
can move into those
environments and then
optimize on the differences.
So for us, memory
was a big problem.
We have the typical
memory problems
like any web application--
JavaScript, entities.
You substantiate a few thousand
objects, you got a problem.
You substantiate a bunch of DOM
elements, you got a problem.
The thing that
surprised us most was
what we found when we got into
the graphics and rendering
layer of these browsers.
So we started out by
getting into the PS3.
And we were crashing
basically every 15 minutes
or so when we first
built the application.
And we had to sort of learn why.
Why are we crashing?
Well, we figured out there
was some rendering problem.
We were working with
our browser team that
also was porting
Chromium to that device.
And they started talking
about, hey, your rendering
is taking a long time.
Your rendering is
causing problems.
It's fragmenting memory.
So we had to say
what's a render layer?
Well, a rendering
layer is a bitmap
that the browser creates when
compositing visual elements
for display on the screen.
Now, each render layer costs
you width times height times 4.
So this is-- you can think
of a browser window, right?
You've got the width
of the browser,
the height of the browser.
You multiply it times 4.
Well, why 4?
Well, OK, you've got the red
channel, the green channel,
the blue channel, and
then the alpha channel.
So basically when the browser
takes your application,
it loads the full
screen, creates
a render layer of
the full screen.
Then it breaks up
your DOM elements.
And at many of those
points in your tree,
it'll actually create
another render layer
that's the size of that
element and its children.
So in our case, when
you saw those tiles,
we get a different render
layer for each of those tiles.
Now as the browser
renders every frame
it's splitting up all of those
entities into render layers,
creating bitmaps, and then
compositing them together
into a single bitmap.
So when we got to
PS3-- this is just
an example of what our
application looks like.
And this is what
I'm talking about.
Each of these rectangles is
essentially a render layer.
We got to the PS3
our graphics memory
was looking a lot like this.
So as we go over
time, our memory
was essentially getting
allocated and then freed
and then allocated and freed,
and, allocated and freed.
And even though we actually
had enough free memory
to do what we needed to
do, we were fragmenting it
with this process.
And that's what was
causing the crash.
We couldn't get enough
contiguous memory
to allocate what
we needed to render
another frame after about
10 minutes of moving around.
So we dug in.
Well, what does
make a render layer?
How do we control this thing?
Is there any way
we can control it?
We found that there's
a few CSS styles
that you apply to elements
that causes the browser
to generate a render layer.
Of course, we get
the root layer.
But also, if you set absolute
or relative positioning
in any element, CSS
opacity and transforms
force a render layer.
Now, once we dug into that,
we realized we could actually
sit down and force render layers
to stop compositing and stay
resident in memory over time by
using hacks that were publicly
available at the time and
are no longer good to do
on desktop environments but were
great in the TV environment.
And for example, I'm
talking about translateZ.
So we told the browser,
hey, put this element
and its children into a single
bitmap and keep it there
and don't free it
on every frame.
Once we did that,
our PS3 usage--
our memory usage on
rendering looked a lot more
like this red line.
It became a lot more stable.
And our application runtimes
grew beyond six hours.
So this was a huge
difference for us,
just learning how CSS works
in these browser environments
and getting that
performance under control.
Now, Steven's going to come up
here and talk to you about how
we got video playback to work.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Thanks, Luke.
So on the player
infrastructure team,
our goal is to
deliver you video that
starts fast, looks great,
and never rebuffers.
We're not there yet.
So if you typed in "why is"
into Google not too long ago,
you'd actually see one of
the top results come up is,
"Why is YouTube so slow?"
This is a serious problem for
our creators and our viewers,
and we're committed
to solving it.
One of our best tools for
doing so is adaptive streaming.
With adaptive streaming,
we take a video
and split it into chunks.
And by making requests for
those chunks independently,
we get a lot more
flexibility over how
we deal with changing or
just bad network conditions.
Now, that flexibility
isn't unlimited.
The media pipelines
are, well, pipelined.
So as you introduce
media data, it sort of
locks you in for a few seconds.
And any time you make a
decision about what to do,
that decision is
going to constrain
your options for the
next few seconds.
So you have to make
the right choice,
otherwise we might
show a buffer spinner
or we'll show video quality
that's unnecessarily too low.
That means that
every time we make
an ABR choice we're
predicting the future,
figuring out what's
going to happen.
And that's always hard.
Which is why we spend so
much time tuning the crap out
of this algorithm.
So we use-- the primary
method for doing
so is an AB test framemark
that lets us run experiments
on real user metrics.
And we're testing not just
for quantitative performance,
such as whether or not the user
saw a buffer spinner, but also
qualitative such as watch time.
And the web platform has
been fantastic for that.
We've seen that by being able to
push code changes to production
so quickly, we iterate
on experiments.
In fact, my personal average
is about two new experiments
launched per week.
And you couldn't have that sort
of serialized dependency of we
learned something, we move on,
and create a new experiment
that applies that learning on a
platform that had a longer lead
time.
So this has been
tremendously advantageous.
But, as Luke mentioned,
we have a player binary
that runs on multiple
device platforms,
but they're all built
on the web platform.
And this has really
had an unexpected level
of benefit in terms of
being able to deploy
the same code across multiple
platforms at the same time.
So I'll give you some examples.
We had a device.
It was one of the TV
HTML5 style devices.
And this device would
buffer, for no reason
that we could tell initially.
It'd be on a great network.
If you were streaming
video from another computer
or mobile device,
that would work fine.
But on this device, the video
would enter a buffering state
and it would never leave it.
You'd just have the
spinner up there
for the rest of your session.
If you'd seek, it'd
sort of snap out of it,
but we didn't want that.
We wanted users to just have
an uninterrupted experience.
And so, we knew that
this was happening
because we have
instrumentation in the player.
We have quality of
experience metrics
that show us what
the player is doing
from a client-side perspective.
And then we join that with what
we know our video streaming
servers are doing, so that
we can get a perspective.
And with this device, we saw
that the streaming servers'
view of the connection
was all great.
People had a strong connection
to YouTube, so it wasn't that,
but the client was still
encountering those rebuffers.
So we needed more detail.
We built a solution
using standard XML
HTTP progress events
that allows us
to get more insight
into requests.
So this is what you're seeing.
The horizontal
axis here is time.
The vertical is data
rate, which is basically
the user's bandwidth.
And this is a single request
that we're looking at.
And we can see that the
request starts great,
and then for some
reason it just cuts off
to this extremely low
bandwidth condition.
But critically, it's
not zero bandwidth.
There was still a packet
coming in every few seconds.
And that meant our time-out
logic wasn't triggering,
because the number
of bytes was still
going up within
the time-out time.
And so once we identified
that this was happening
in correlation with
those infinite rebuffers,
we started digging deeper
at the level of TCP.
And we found that
what was happening
was this device
had a flaky radio.
It would disconnect for
a fraction of a second
and come back, but when it did,
all of the packets on the wire
already were dropped.
And so you'd end
up with hundreds of
dropped packets and selective
acknowledgements going back
to the server for that.
This would put TCP
in a weird state
where the congestion window
would clamp down and not
reopen.
It would take a long
time for that to happen.
And so that's what was
causing these events.
Once we knew that, we were
able to go back to the player,
use the same standard
browser technology
to detect this condition.
It's a little
finicky because you
needed to work around
situations that
were real bandwidth changes.
But we had a solution
in place that
was able to detect this and
then simply cancel the request
and start a new one.
And the new request
would of course
work great, because it
was a new TCP session.
So this saved the device.
Its own performance went
from basically unusable
to very substantially good.
On TV as a whole,
this experiment
led to a 60% less time
spent rebuffering.
But what surprised us was that
when we ran this experiment
we ran it across all
platforms simultaneously,
because it's essentially free
to do so using the web platform.
And we found out
that it was also
improving the
experience on desktops.
We didn't even know
we had this problem.
And the reason why
was we introduced
all of our instrumentation
about the player
well after this problem
started appearing on desktops.
And on desktops, users have
learned that if they seek,
the request will be canceled.
And they'll start a new one.
So they were essentially
emulating the same behavior
that we are able to
add to our player.
But they had to
do that manually,
which meant it interrupted
the experience.
Some users didn't
figure this out.
It was bad all around.
So having this single view
where we can take our learning
and apply it seamlessly
across devices
can allow us to understand
much more about the player
as it reacts in
different environments
to different stimuli.
And so we can have this
learning on all of our platforms
simultaneously.
Now, there's another
sort of learning
that you can get from
multi-platform devices,
and this is a case
of divergence.
So we have an input
bandwidth signal.
And again, this
is the same style
of graph captured from clients.
Horizontal axis is time,
vertical axis is data rate.
We're going to talk about
the two signals separately.
And if you think you've
seen a lot of graphs today,
you're not wrong.
So these are the two signals.
The first one is
exemplary of a condition
that you might find
on a laptop computer.
Most of our desktop
site usage is actually
coming from laptops these days.
And of course, you
can take that laptop
and move it to another room.
If you do that, you
might experience
a change in your
Wi-Fi signal strength,
corresponding
change in bandwidth.
We want a bandwidth filter to
respond quickly to that change,
and so that's why
on desktop we use
a multi-tap rolling
percentile filter.
Basically this means we look at
the past few seconds of data.
We evaluate what the 40th,
50th, 60th percentiles are.
We use that composite metric
to make our ABR decisions on.
And you can see it does.
It tracks this with
a very short lag.
It tracks this input signal
and essentially rejects
all of its old history.
Now, on TV we do
something different.
On TV the experience
is different.
The devices don't have
the memory to buffer head,
so we can't offer
a forced HD button.
And we find that users on
TV desire HD a lot more.
So even though it's not
quite as responsive,
we use an exponentially
weighted moving average on TV.
And we discovered
this-- we didn't
know that this solution
was going to work.
We were actually just
trying things out
across all of our
platforms at once.
We found that one
filter worked better
on one platform and another on a
different set of circumstances,
for a lot of reasons.
But these are some of them.
And that's critical,
because we didn't
expect there to be
these differences.
We sort of found out that once
we had arrived at this test
configuration, we saw
these different responses
on different devices.
And we were able to
take advantage of that.
One more example signal.
This is a very spiky signal.
A lot of outliers here.
If you're seeing this
on a desktop device
you might be surprised,
because in most circumstances
there are glitches like that,
but they're not so regular.
Those are sort of aberrations.
And the sliding percentile
window used on desktop
does a great job of
rejecting those signals.
On TV, we actually want to
incorporate those signals
because it turns out that that's
how those devices communicate.
Their radios tends to lock
on and transmit in bursts
more often.
And so it's appropriate for that
weighted average to do this.
And again, we would not have
discovered these differences
if we didn't have
the platform that
allowed us to run all of those
experiments on every platform
simultaneously.
We didn't anticipate
this being a need,
but by having all of that
information available,
we were able to really
lean in on the differences
in the platform and do
comparative analyses
all at the same time with
essentially no overhead
in terms of our experimentation.
So all of that has been
fantastic for optimizing
our delivery of adaptive
video on multiple devices.
And for a sort of view on
how well we're doing in this,
this is people searching for
"YouTube PS3 slow" over time.
That point right
there, where it drops
to essentially zero,
that's when we introduced
adaptive streaming on the PS3.
So we are making progress.
We're hardly done yet.
We've got a lot more way to go,
but this-- the web technology
has allowed us to
iterate extremely quickly
and build a solution
that's great for users.
Now, we're also interested
in moving the web forward.
Not just using the web
platform as a method
for moving YouTube forward,
but actually advancing
the web platform itself.
So one example for
this is Media Source.
Media Source is
the way that we did
everything I just talked about.
It's the adaptive
streaming solution
as part of the web platform.
And it's essential for all of
the adaptive streaming to work.
It's the way that we communicate
with the browser stack.
That took essentially
three years, maybe four
if you count the
initial time when
it started being
worked on internally.
But it still took three years
to get universal adoption.
And we think that
this should be faster.
So as sort of a counter
example, you can consider VP9.
VP9 is a technology
that allows us
to deliver twice the video
quality at a given connection.
So if you could only play
480p, you can now hit 720.
And it's not a strict
apples to apples comparison
there, because VP9 is
more of a web technology
rather than a web standard.
But the fact is that we started
looking at VP9 in earnest--
we published this
spec about a year ago.
And right now it's used
billions of times per day.
It's making people's
experience dramatically better.
And it's seen adoption
across a number of browsers.
In fact, by this
time next year, we
expect it to be in hundreds
or thousands of unique device
models.
And this kind of
coverage is possible
because there was a huge
joint effort between YouTube,
one of the largest consumers of
video, between the Chrome team,
but also between YouTube's
external hardware partners,
between a lot of hardware and
software companies working
with the Chrome team on
extending their reach,
between the Android team as
they push out the platform.
So getting the adoption of
these technologies universally
is important.
It allows us to accelerate
the development-- not just
of apps using the web platform,
but of the web platform itself.
And we're looking
forward to doing
more of that to continue
to advance this experience.
All right, thank you very much.
If you have--
[APPLAUSE]
STEVEN ROBERTSON: If
you have questions,
please come up to the mics.
We'd be happy to answer them.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the talk.
It was very informative.
So a lot of this stuff is
a little bit over my head,
so maybe this question
won't make much sense,
but you talked a lot about
HTML5 and the broader web.
And you just mentioned VP9 being
implemented by major browsers.
What is the situation in
embedded devices land?
Like, is VP9 supported
by smart TVs?
And more so HTML5 standards.
LUKE BAYES: So that's
actually a great question.
When I talked about us working
with the SOC manufacturers,
so we've actually
been working closely
with the people making
the chips to get
VP9 decoding at
the hardware level.
And when we do that,
essentially all of our partners
get it for free with the
next generation of devices.
So this is coming to TVs.
This is coming to smart
Blu-ray disc players.
This is coming to over-the-top
boxes, set-top boxes.
This is the kind of
movement that we're really
excited about.
So yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Thank you for a nice talk.
I was wondering, you mentioned
that you support some input
from consoles, but web doesn't
really support all of that.
At least not the Xbox thingy
that tracks your movement.
So how do you do that?
LUKE BAYES: So that's actually
another great question.
So we have these very
interesting and unique input
devices.
And there are
cases where we have
to move a little bit
outside of web standards
and expose another interface
at the browser level.
But there are also cases where
we could treat, for example,
gestures.
We were able to implement
that at our application layer
as if it were a mouse.
And so we were able to hide
that abstraction in the browser
itself and then expose
it to the JavaScript
as if it was just a mouse input.
So we were able to use the
[INAUDIBLE] web standards
to take advantage of things that
don't appear on their surface
to be a part of a web standards.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like you
guys spent three years building
a platform to ensure
good web delivery
to a variety of devices.
But every other video company
that's trying to deliver video
faces these same problems.
So what should they do
if they're not YouTube?
LUKE BAYES: Yeah, so we
actually work with many of them,
as it turns out.
So we work pretty
closely with many
of these other video providers.
And they're leveraging some
of the same technologies
that we do especially on
these device environments.
AUDIENCE: I will talk to you.
LUKE BAYES: Great.
AUDIENCE: How are you doing?
I had a question
about developers
who are building on top
of the YouTube platform.
Currently the YouTube
APIs are quite rich
and are getting
better every day,
but there still are
limitations that
obviously the
things you presented
don't have to deal with.
For example, on desktop
apps, developers
have to interface with
the YouTube videos
through the iFrame, which
your apps don't have to do.
And then on other
platforms it may not
be possible if there's
no developer API.
So I'm curious just
kind of how you
see the ecosystem
continue to evolve.
Do you see APIs being
developed to allow developers
to work on top of the YouTube
platform on game consoles
and other devices like that?
LUKE BAYES: Do you want to--
I can talk about consoles.
Yeah, so, one of the
other things that came up
is in these embedded devices
and device environments--
part of your question is
about interacting with YouTube
directly from within
another application.
There's another
aspect of it which
is about presenting
YouTube content
but playing it back
in our application.
And so there's an
aspect of that where
our device partners,
for example,
are using YouTube's APIs to
show YouTube content to users,
and even personalized content
outside of our application.
And then when a user
selects that content
they can play it back
directly in our application.
And this is an area where
every device partner has
a very different way of
messaging from one application
environment to another.
But because we're on the web,
we are able to simply use URLs.
We're able to say, hey, just
feed us a properly structured
URL and we can launch the right
video or the right channel
or the right playlist
and get the user
the experience they're
really looking for.
I think that second
part of your question
is actually very important.
And we are working on trying
to improve those teams.
There's a lot of tradeoffs
there in terms of security
and monetization
and trustworthiness.
So there are issues there,
but we're definitely
trying to improve the
ecosystem across the web.
But it's a long road there.
AUDIENCE: Good.
Thank you very much.
LUKE BAYES: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Can you
go into any detail
or give us a general overview
into how you collect and report
on those metrics that
you made available
across all those platforms?
LUKE BAYES: There's
one for Strobe.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Sure.
So we have infrastructure that
collects anonymized statistics
based on the
individual playbacks.
And some of that is
measured within the browser.
So we have just JavaScript
code that executes.
We look at current time and
have this really gnarly,
denoising algorithm
to work around
a bunch of pathologies in
a lot of the older devices.
Newer devices are
better in part--
and actually in
substantial part--
because as part of the
YouTube certification program,
we're making sure that devices
have clean input reporting
and conform to the specs.
So on the newer devices
it's just not as necessary.
But we generate all
of that information
from looking at the signals
that the device itself generates
and then just
making sure that it
does what we expect when
it logs those things.
And then for the
server side, just as
part of normal
server side logging,
we grab all of that
information about the video.
And we actually do--
it's more than just
per request information.
We'll look at some
values over time,
such as a sampled
bandwidth or something.
And we use a lot of
that and combine it
in order to get an aggregated
view of the performance
of each device as it's
playing back video.
Is there a particular
question that you had or--
AUDIENCE: Just
wondered in general.
LUKE BAYES: Our
client and servers
are both instrumented to
emit into a logging pipeline.
And then we have lots
and lots of analytics
around that logging.
There's actually a
privacy story there
that was really
fascinating for me
when I joined the organization.
I had this expectation like,
Google knows everything,
it's amazing!
And when I got to
YouTube, I found
that I wasn't allowed to access
most of the things I really
was interested in finding.
So I want to look at what
this particular user did,
because they just
reported a bug.
I'm not allowed to
see that information.
So our logging pipeline,
as Steven said,
is actually anonymized.
It's very difficult to look
at a particular session
or a particular interaction.
We end up looking at things
in aggregate and anonymized.
So it's this weird
thing where it's
like, I really want
to see these details,
but I'm actually not allowed.
So that was a strange moment
for me when I discovered that.
I was like, oh, the people
actually doing these things
don't have access to a
lot of the information
I thought they did.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a pretty-- a question
to the development
of the platform.
So as you said that you
used the web platform.
And over the web platform
you were developing the API,
developing the software
for the YouTube platform
over TV as well as for the
desktop and everything,
using the same things.
And what happened was that while
you were developing for the TV,
you realized that there were
some things which, actually--
like the example
that you gave-- were
that little improvement
to the desktop as well,
the desktop experience as well.
So, my question is that there
are so many different kinds
of platforms out there, and
you're using, I would say,
the same piece of software
throughout all the platforms
to render your stuff.
So couldn't it be more better if
you had separate teams for it?
Of course, it would be
the management [INAUDIBLE]
but the [INAUDIBLE] could
be substantially improved
or the performance
could be improved.
LUKE BAYES: That's
something I brushed over.
So we actually do
have different teams
that work on the application
layer of these platforms.
We have a separate team
and a separate binary
and a separate application
for mobile web.
We have a separate team
and a separate application
for the desktop and laptop web.
And then we have a separate
team and application
for the TV application.
Now Steven's team builds
the playback environment.
So they have a single playback
binary that all of those teams
consume, but we do have unique
applications for these very
different input experiences.
STEVEN ROBERTSON:
Yeah, and I think
that the critical
component of that
is that within most
applications there
are teams that go horizontally
for a particular experience.
There are teams that go
vertically for a core concern,
especially if you have a
multi-device experience
that you want.
And being able to structure your
teams in that way is helpful.
Being able to structure
your code in that way
is also really helpful.
And the web platform
lets us do both.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
That was very interesting talk.
I was just wondering if you
guys received a lot of pushback
from any of those
partners when you
came to them with this idea
of really relying on the web.
And also, are you finding any--
LUKE BAYES: They
were so frustrating.
AUDIENCE: And also, are
you finding any platforms
where that just is--
it's just not working?
LUKE BAYES: So we did have
a lot of conversations
early on with partners around
what is the right technology
to deliver this application.
And there was a lot
of back and forth
with what the right
decision was there.
We were able to get universal
adoption in the TV environment,
mainly because as soon
as we had any application
on these devices, our partners
learned that their users spend
most of their time
in our application.
So they realized if they
put our logo in their box,
they sell more TVs.
They realize that
they put them--
that people are using
their device more.
So we had a certain
amount of leverage.
And we were able to put this
environment into these devices
that we think will benefit
a lot more organizations--
other organizations
in addition to ours.
And, sorry, what was the
second part of your question?
AUDIENCE: Are
there any platforms
where that strategy is
just really not working?
LUKE BAYES: Absolutely.
So we currently
have-- in the TV team,
we actually have
a native team that
builds an application
for the Xbox 360.
So there are
platforms that we just
can't get what we want there.
And we will lean
into those as needed,
but we try extremely hard to
get on to the web platform.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks a lot.
LUKE BAYES: Any other questions?
All right.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Thank you.
LUKE BAYES: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]